on lui parle en direct de paris bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous pour sa
probité alors parlons-en justement de ce
que c'est d'abord swift ou est ce que
c'est si tu essaies où le siège social
de cette organisation
alors swift est une organisation
internationale dont le siège se trouve à
bruxelles c'est une organisation qui est
écrit dans les années 70 pour venir
sécuriser les échanges interbancaires
c'est un système de communication qui
permet à des banques quotidiennement vos
le vivier à hauteur de plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'opérations par
jour d'échangés de manière sécurisée sur
des flux financiers internationaux et
nationaux est-ce que la russie en a
besoin est ce que c'est crucial pour ce
pays
c'est nécessaire pour la russie parce
que la russie est un partenaire
commercial important de l'union
européenne du canada d'une telle ligne
de beaucoup de pays occidentaux et au
delà et dès que la russie souhaite
échanger avec d'autres banques partout
dans le monde elle se sert également du
réseau swift pour effectuer des
opérations un petit peu partout dans le
monde bon si on exclut effectivement
banni la russie de systèmes et genre de
désorganisation ça peut causer pour ce
pays
d'une organisation assez massive parce
que c'est un système qui est donc en
place depuis près de 50 ans et donc
c'est un système qui est vraiment le
système privilégié par les banques pour
des communications sur des opérations
simples mais aussi sur des opérations
contacts par exemple tout ce qui est
crédit documentaire tous qui toutes les
garanties que des banques peuvent
émettre sur des projets internationaux
complexes c'est par swift que ça passait
donc fait de ne pas avoir accès à swift
c'est empêcher du jour au lendemain la
russie de s'organiser de pouvoir
communiquer de manière structurée avec
ses partenaires financiers dans le monde
est ce que ça veut dire que ça pourrait
étouffer économiquement la russie ça
veut dire quoi dans les faits
dans les faits c'est ce que swift seul
peut étouffer la russie je ne pense pas
je pense que c'est le cumul de plusieurs
choses je pense que les sanctions qui
sont par ailleurs prises par les pays
occidentaux le canada je vois que votre
premier a également adopté des sanctions
est troisième avec de sanction de cette
fin d'après midi des états unis votre
voisin également les pays européens
adoptent des sanctions contre le secteur
bancaire qui ne sont pas des sanctions
sucre qui sont des sanctions qui visent
les principales banques commerciales du
pays donc c'est le cumul de ces
sanctions contre vtb contre ce verbe
encore ne citer que ces deux grandes
banques commerciales et privés la russie
d'accès à ce risque qui pourrait
effectivement sur le moyen et long terme
venir et tout fait le système bancaire
us puisque la russe est déjà dans un
mode attaque de puits au delà de 24
heures maintenant pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'a pas déjà jouer cette carte-là dollar
series système swift
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'il se
passerait on a seulement en précédent
c'est l'iran en 2012 puis à nouveau
depuis 2018 et on ne sait pas l'iran est
un pays avec lequel il ya des liens
commerciaux importants mais qui ne sont
absolument pas comparable aux liens
commerciaux que l'occident entretien et
même d'ailleurs l'asie entretien avec là
aussi donc on ne sait pas c'est un peu
comme si on appuyer sur un bouton sans
savoir exactement ce qu'il allait se
passer on ne sait pas quelles vont être
les conséquences pour les banques qui
sont partenaires de certains et
certaines versions russes on sait par
exemple qu'en europe les allemagne l
italie qui hier soir ce sont a priori
dans un premier temps opposée du moins à
cette option ont peur de ne pas pouvoir
payer par exemple d un parent de gaz ils
font quotidiennement aux riches
et donc de grosses conséquences
effectivement même pour des banques
occidentales et pour des pays
occidentaux lorsque vous êtes en train
de dire c'est qu'il ya des pays qui font
affaire avec la russie évidemment il ya
tout ce secteur liées aux ressources
énergétiques pour l'europe il ya un lien
de dépendance très très fort parce que
clairement de l'allemagne envers la
russie ne pas être capable de payer ses
factures
ça peut me dire on se prit finalement je
romps pourrait avoir une crise
énergétique c'est ce que vous êtes en
trenchs et
c'est effectivement ça après ça pourrait
aussi ainsi d inciter la russie à ne pas
à ne plus poursuivre ses exports des
carburants et de et de gaz dans la
russie dans la loi par dont a
cruellement besoin comme vous le
soulignez très justement donc c'est
cette crainte qui aujourd'hui a mis sa
rendre deux pays sur la retenue même si
on voit de plus en plus je voyais
aujourd'hui par exemple le conseil de
l'union européenne a évolué sur ce
prendre l'allemagne semble se ranger
aujourd'hui derrière le canada derrière
le royaume-uni la france derrière les
etats-unis qui maintenant semble de plus
en plus concrètement considérer cette
option sur la mesure de la progression
des de la ruche dans dans le pays dans
l'ukraine et dans les rues de kiev mais
qu'est-ce que vous déconnez justement de
l'empressement de certains pays de
passer à cette option alors que d'autres
sont plus frileux finalement c'est qu'il
y en a qui ont moins à perdre du retrait
de l'allemagne de système que
d'ordinaire des gens qui sont à moins
dans une position qui est un peu moins
fragile et finalement la face à la
russie oui tout dépend finalement de la
balance commerciale que l'on a avec la
russie il ya des pays qui sont plus ou
moins exposée la russie je pense que par
exemple de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
le canada les états-unis sont certes
l'exposait la russie mais si demain il
devait se priver de certains ports en
provenance de russie c'est vraiment de
conséquences directes sur le
consommateur sur les populations dans
des pays comme l'allemagne l'italie la
finlande il faut vous imaginer que par
exemple pour un exemple très très
criants le triche plus de 90% de son gaz
aujourd'hui et en provenance de russie
donc de fait si demande par exemple si
un accord venait à être stoppée on
risque une crise énergétique et surtout
une pénurie massive de gaz qui
viendraient affecter le consommateur
autrichien même si des pays disent la
communauté internationale sentant venir
la russie de swift mais swift est ce qui
se fait commander effectivement par la
communauté internationale ou est ce que
c'est ça un certain niveau d'autonomie
ce système là
alors c'est un système kerry king
lui-même il faut vous le dit très
justement c'est swift choisi ses clients
et swift fournit des services à des
établissements bancaires c'est vrai que
ça peut paraître un peu paradoxal que
des états imposent et swift qui a une
autonomie ce type de choses mais pour
autant on a quand même un précédent et
je pense qu'il ne faut le souligner en
2018 contre donald trump et les états
unis ont décidé de sortir de l'accord de
vienne est on ré imposer des sanctions
secondaire à l'encontre de l'iran les
états européens n'étaient pas tout à
fait aligner avec cette position bien au
contraire et donc il ya eu en grand
débat entre les états unis et l'union
européenne sur je prends et il a été
décidé par les américains de n'imposer
des sanctions à portée extraterritoriale
qui justement vie la fourniture de
messages financiers et donc qui visait
swift ils suivent s'est retrouvé dans
une position où il a eu à choisir entre
prendre le risque d'être sanctionné par
les états unis parce qu'il continuait de
fournir des services de messagerie à les
ronds ou continuer ses services de
messagerie donc dans ces cas-là l'option
était relativement simple on se range à
la lex americana alors on comprend là
dedans qu'il ya un degré d'autonomie
mais le monde des affaires et parfois
aveugle protège ses propres intérêts
c'est un peu ce que vous êtes
c'est un peu ça effectivement même si le
swift est autonome et même si swift est
une organisation qui n'est a priori pas
à la main de d'état
les lois notamment la loi américaine et
une loi très forte et est
malheureusement quand on risque des
potentiels de sanctions de la part de
cette loi on a tendance par volonté de
s'y conformer à prendre des décisions
qui ne vont pas forcément dans ces trois
présente avec commerciaux mais c'est
extrêmement éclairant comme entrevue
merci beaucoup monsieur d'organes je
vous en prie très bonne fin de journée à
vous à vos vêtements